it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we expose the cultural stories
of the day and for that we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond president zielinski addressed
congress today virtually
he did indeed and he used the address
lore to ask for planes a no-fly zone he
used heart-wrenching video to make his
case then he addressed president biden
directly listen it's not enough to be
the leader of the nation
today it takes to be the leader of the
world being
the leader of the world means
to be the leader of peace
strong
is brave and ready to fight for the life
of his citizens and citizens of the
world
lord now that's a curious uh thing there
i mean god bless zielinski he's facing
this thug putin who is killing civilians
he kills people in his own countries
he's a monster but he's saying here that
somehow
biden has to be a leader of the world a
citizen of the world well no he justice
zielinski is committed to the ukrainian
people first
biden needs to be committed to the
american ideal and that's what he's
doing promoting peace hopefully and and
working for that piece in multiple ways
so i think we need some clarity here and
most americans don't realize laura
zielinski was an actor and comedian who
started in a show called servant of the
people it was about a high school
teacher who finds himself president of
ukraine which the actor eventually
became he named his political party
servant of the people this is an amazing
example of art presaging life watch
we decided to take your country to the
european union
[Music]
all the ukrainians and all of our
country or we've been waiting for this
so much time
ukrainian
yes ukrainians
[Music]
in some ways laura the whole story's
right there the u.s and europe made
overtures putin felt threatened and
zielinski became the ted lasso of the
world leaders club
well meanwhile biden he's looking more
like what anthony hopkins
in the fl and the father
he looks
he was this yesterday yeah yeah this is
yesterday watch
i've got a little change in the
arrangement who's on the stage because
of the first lady's husband uh
contracting covet but uh look at this
room and what you see
that's right she's fine
it's me
that's not together
the second lady the first gentleman
how about that
laura so he had covered the president
doug emoth is the second lady he he's
not sure of anything and i really worry
about the president going to europe
there's some breaking news tonight that
iran nuke deal just to show you how he
says one thing putin is a war criminal
here's what they're doing on the policy
front in that iran nuke deal guess who
gets the 10 billion dollar contract and
all sanctions waived to build the
iranian nuclear plants russia it's in
the iran nuke deal this is mind-blowing
what's happening so this administration
better get its story together with its
policy right now they are at odds well i
would take issue with this idea that
biden is pursuing peace i don't i mean i
think he he sees where he sees he sees
what what obama saw in syria which is
why he stepped back from the red line
drew the red line he shouldn't have
drawn it because he realized uh oh the
american people don't want this so biden
stepped back
i mean obama stepped back and now
biden's kind of doing that same thing he
knows that
it's too risky to get involved in some
you know
protracted military adventure and uh in
ukraine
he's throwing billions at this thing but
i i have to i applaud his restraint
there are a lot of people on the left
and the right telling him send planes
we've got to do more zielinski's doing
the big emotional push this is sober
states craft if he sticks to the plan
but this iran nuke deal contradicts
everything he's saying one good bit of
news on the ukraine front pope francis
had a video call with patriarch carrillo
moscow who supported putin's invasion
the pope told him today war is always
unjust and that they as religious
leaders must not use the language of
politics but the language of jesus he's
also doing a big consecration on march
25th consecrating the country of russia
which is a big deal and an important one
i believe this is the first time in the
ingram angle that raymond arroyo has
said said something truly
just completely positive about pope
francis so that's no that's not true i
report the truth ingram look finally if
zielinski was looking for a citizen of
the world leader he should have turned
on netflix barack obama is hosting a new
documentary called our national parks
yosemite or glacial bay what global
national parks laura
join me in this celebration of our
planet's greatest national parks and
wilderness this sleepy sloth
might just save us all this is a journey
through the natural wonders
of our shared birthright
[Music]
laura along with the one billion dollars
of armaments i hope obama sends the
sleepy sloth to ukraine they could use
the help the sleepy sloth was that a
digget biden what was that i mean no
it's a sleepy slaw the new tree at one
of these he's doing parks
he got 100 he and michelle got 125
million in their netflix deal was it
looks like he was in hawaii just worse
green screen in the back and it was so
nice
now it looks it looks like a nice show
beautiful footage
yeah well 125 million dollars raymond
thank you so much